你知道嗎？今天看到一個案例，讓我覺得蠻有意思的，是關於一家叫 Function 的公司。他們的共同創辦人 Pranitha Patil，本來在哈佛讀書，結果為了這間公司輟學了。
輟學？哈佛欸，這出乎意料了。通常大家聽到哈佛，都覺得是為了學歷或名聲努力，怎麼會為了創業就放棄？這家公司到底在做什麼，讓她這麼有信心？
就是因為他們的模式很不一樣。這家公司提供一種會員制的健康管理服務，不只做一般的抽血檢測，還會結合更多維度的數據，像 MRI、CT 掃描，甚至加上 AI 分析，幫你「看懂」自己的健康狀況。
聽起來跟坊間的健康檢查好像差不多？現在很多健康中心也提供這些服務啊，高階健檢也包含這些項目。他們到底特別在哪？能讓一位哈佛生放棄學位，還創造出 25 億美元的市值。
不一樣的點就在於「深度」和「預防」。Patil 她自己年輕時就有 PCOS 和糖尿病前期問題，但當時的醫療系統只在她有問題才介入。她們這家公司 Function，是想在這些問題還沒變成大病之前，就先幫你抓出來。
嗯，這點我有點懂了。等於說，他們不是等人生病了才處理，而是提早預警，幫你解讀那些醫生可能沒空細講的數據，對吧？但要怎麼「提早預警」？醫生不是也會給建議嗎？
他們的關鍵就是「AI 驅動」的個人化洞察。Function 不只給你看檢測結果，還會用 AI 幫你把這些資訊統整起來，包括你的生物年齡，然後告訴你下一步可以怎麼做。他們的會員年費是 365 美元，但如果自己去外面做這些檢測，可能要花到 1 萬 5 千美元。
等等，一年 365 美元，就能做那麼多高階檢測，還包含 AI 分析？這個價格是怎麼壓下來的？我猜是會員數夠多，攤提掉成本？還是檢測項目有打折？這聽起來有點不可思議。
原文有提到，他們一開始就是從大規模的實驗室檢測切入。他們目標是快速達到八十億用戶，AI 就是他們達成這個目標的手段。而且，他們還透過併購來擴大規模，增加像是影像檢測這些服務。
這樣說來，等於他們是先用大量的檢測數據打底，然後用 AI 去解讀這些數據，創造新的價值。所以，它吸引人的不是單純的檢測服務，而是檢測背後那套「數據解讀與行動方案」的流程。這就有點像以前的健檢報告，後面附註一堆數字，但其實沒幾個人看得懂。
對，就是這個意思。而且他們還有私人 AI 聊天功能，讓你針對報告結果直接跟 AI 溝通，幫助你理解並制定計畫。這其實就像有個專屬的健康顧問，但成本低得多。
這樣一來，對於創業者或企業主管，我覺得學到的是，即使在已經很成熟的產業，像健康醫療，你還是可以找到「數據」這個切入點。把散亂的數據整合起來，再用新技術去解讀它，就能創造出新的商業模式。
我很同意。而且，它不只是數據整合，更重要的是提供「可行動」的建議。就像我們開店，不只是收集顧客資料，更要從這些資料中看出顧客的偏好，然後調整產品或服務。
那對於一般上班族來說呢？這個案例好像有點遙遠，畢竟我們又沒法自己弄個 AI 系統來管理健康。
其實我覺得，它提醒我們可以把「預防」的概念帶入工作中。不是等到專案出問題才去救火，而是定期檢視手上的工作進度、資源配置，像做健檢一樣，看看哪裡有潛在的「紅字」，提早做調整。
你說的是把健康管理的思維，應用到工作流程上？這有點意思。就像 Function 幫你找到生物年齡，我們也可以試著找出工作或團隊的「疲勞指標」或「風險因子」，不要等到快崩潰了才意識到。
沒錯。透過定期的自我審視或團隊檢視，把那些看似零散的數據或現象串聯起來，或許就能避免許多大問題。好像也提醒了我們，很多時候，問題的答案就藏在那些我們平常容易忽略的細節裡。